ce n'est pas tout
bon
c'est
massive attack
jean
jamais
cazilhac est ce que c'est françois tu
m'as fait peur qu'est-ce que tu prépares
d'autres de william hill
je suis en train de me préparer un
gloubi boulga à quoi un gloubi boulga du
tome expliquer de quoi il s'agit comment
un truc une sais pas ce que c'est mais
c'est mon dessert préféré je te le 13
août et dès qu'il sera prêt franchement
j'ai jamais entendu parler de ce dessert
et semir tu crois qu'il me plairait à
mossoul tout le monde tout le monde ne
peut qu'adorer le cloud by bull ical et
qu'est ce que tu as mis ton de dire
qu'il ya d'abord du chocolat en poudre à
chocolat en poudre et de la confiture de
fraises la confiture de fraise j'adore
ça de la banane écrasée dans l'année
grâce et c'est très bien c'est très bien
avec de la moutarde de la moutarde
oui et de la saucisse de toulouse aide
de la banane écrasée du chocolat en
poudre de la confiture de groseilles
avec de la moutarde et de la saucisse de
toulouse
ah oui mais attention l'associé de
toulouse est est tiède mais mes papilles
8 mai mais c'est épouvantable casimir
est vraiment seul ouais pourquoi non
face à pas l'air très appétissants
or mais je je ne comprends pas tout le
monde ne peut qu'adorer le gloubiboulga
est ce que vous pourriez aimer le
gloubiboulga ou non un écoute casimir tu
peux aimer le looping à cet endroit
enfin c'est pas une raison pour croire
que tous ceux qui aiment sa note aucun
doute mais oui je crois que tu ne
connaissais pas apprécié ce qui est beau
c'est c'est tellement délicieux le
gloubiboulga enfin tu vas voir les
enfants les voir bien bienfaitrice saufs
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
gloubiboulga vous savez pas non mais je
vous le dire c'est ce qu'a dans le bol
de casimir c'est un mélange de banane
écrasée de confiture de fraises de
chocolat en poudre avec de la moutarde
et on est et de la saucisse de toulouse
et de la saucisse de toulouse on a fait
attention et la saucisse de toulouse
tiède mais cruel cru tiède n'ai cru ça
vous tente vous êtes en manger du
gloubiboulga n'ont vraiment pas aidé du
bras casimir à ces c'est vraiment
désespérant de vivre dans un univers où
tous les gens personne n'a le même goût
que vous ce serait si merveilleux de
vivre dans un monde où tout le monde
aimerait le gloubiboulga
tu me donne encore un peu de temps lobby
brigue à casimir c'est vraiment nos
desserts préférés ça qui est terrible
c'est que tout le monde dans l'île veut
manger du bio divulgua et qu'il n'y a
plus de confiture de fraises bout de
saucisse de travaux m'ont tenu à paris
qu il ne me reste même pas peu de gluck
yoga pour moi arrêter voilà mon pauvre
casimir
je ne demanderai toujours comment du peu
aimée de la saucisse de toulouse
tiennent les crues avec de la banane
écrasée de la confiture de fraises et de
la moutarde
ben tu tu n'aime pas ça or pas du tout
linge je comprends pas pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez tous voulaient manger mon
globi boulga tout à l'heure le temps du
tout casimir pas du tout j'ai dû faire f
2,8 endormir ah et bien finalement
j'aime mieux ça comme ça je vais pouvoir
manger mon globi brugat tous aller sera
là et je crois qu'il vaut beaucoup mieux
ne pas vivre dans un monde où tous les
genres et les mêmes goûts que les états
unis avaient propre soir gagnent
mongolie guide mon globules diarra a
disparu au jeu c'est tu as mangé tout à
l'heure en dormant sans s'en rendre
compte
obama non non non
oi oi oi oi
hu
et oui récré a2 c'est votre émission
tous les jours pendant les vacances je
ne vais pas être seul pour vous la
présentez rassurez vous je suis en
compagnie d'un goût dit vous dis
qu'est-ce que ce cas vous dis goody
c'est un héros gentil d'un western c'est
ça sa baby thébaud mony goody 2 vous dit
vous dit ça de grandes jambes winter qui
fait une bonne tête quand même vous pour
bien bronzer les belles dents blanches
un regard pétillant et plein de
tendresse et d'intelligence parfois
ouais non elle ça joue la musique
paraît-il au pistolet tu tires beaucoup
plus vite que tout le monde je suis le
plus fort en danger
en amour c'est gérard hier ça vous tire
de situations les plus périlleuses pour
sûr dorothée tué la fille du soleil
je vais t'emmener dans ma dit jean
sainte nous allons nous enfuir en loin
des avions way le bétail a passé la
frontière voit la natation pas tombé en
arrière et bien écoute match à dorothée
moi aussi je suis très content d'être à
récré a2 et je ne suis pas venu comme ça
j'ai apporté des petites chansons pour
toi l'europe et les petites chansons
seulement comme je ne savais pas quel
genre de chansons de tuer mais alors
j'en ai composé trois petits trois
petites différentes
une ballade rock and roll 1 une petite
berceuse est prêt depuis coûte alors
dans les tuyaux
qui d'un livre d'histoire à jour s'est
envolé corps elle connaît des secrets
les torts sont ses amis elle fait
chanter les oreilles
je veux être ton ami que tu me racontes
des histoires de sourire
tu es comme mon ami
pour m'apprendre à chanter comme un
grand cas tu as alors manier aussi
dorothée que tu es aimé danser que tu
dansais très bien et que tu dansais
aussi je marque alors je lui peut
chanter le taux voté work frangy
dorothée avec moi je veux danser
dorothée à l'école de chant mais voulait
dire on va bien on va bien s'amuser
ils ont vécu
là
en plus de beaucoup plus calme
maintenant monsieur bien une petite
berceuse tu veux la panthère c'est la
première rose mais elle est tombée dans
un encrier alors la petite berceuse ça
fait de dorothée dort sur ton oreiller
je viendrai s'éveiller
d'or d'or dorothée dans la nuit de l'été
les oiseaux ont chanté
rêve rêves de beauté
au dessin animé
aux histoires et rêves vos rêves dont
parmi
dans tes yeux aux ouvriers
le
une
but quand des yeux
je crois que non
amélie
quand même
devant les tranquilles et quand on est
bien la reine un peu discuté aux livres
articles
bienvenue à bord du temps x vaisseau
aliot nique de deuxième génération à
immersion hyperspatial semaine dernière
nous avons donc quitté le sol de la lune
et aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir pour la
première fois de vous accueillir à bord
de notre vaisseau mère à bord de notre
module de commande et ensemble pendant
toute une année nous allons découvrir
faire autour au cours d'un long voyage
une découverte d'autres mondes possibles
d'autres temps et d'autres intelligences
organisé avec leurs craintes leurs
espoirs leurs enthousiasmes
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir je suis très heureux de vous
présenter pour la première fois ce soir
le nouveau jeu darmangeat mots des
chiffres et des lettres comme tel
constat c'est ce jeu est très simple et
je vais pas vous ennuyer trop longtemps
avec des explications un peu fastidieuse
en fait qu'il reprend le principe du mot
le plus long que beaucoup d'entre vous
connaissent et ils retrouveront j'espère
avec plaisir mais dans cette émission
armand jammot associé au mot le plus
long à nouveau jeu de chiffres
nous appellerons le compte est bon et
qui va vous permettre de faire les
opérations de calcul mental
d'ailleurs je vais pas vous donner de
plus longues explications vous allez
découvrir ce jeu en jouant avec nous et
avec surtout avec nos candidats quant à
dire qu'ils ont fait le plaisir de bien
vouloir inaugurait ce jeu et qui eux
bien entendu maintenant on connaissent
parfaitement les règles je présente
d'abord à ma droite madame coux bonsoir
madame coxeurs donnez nous quelques
quelques petits renseignements sur vous
pour la première fois que vous êtes
mariée mère de famille qui s'appelle
comment alexandra je pense qu'elle n'a
pas encore comprendre que nous sommes en
train de fermer un camp star qui nous
restait pendant dix semaines peut-être
que les renault alto et de l'autre côté
monsieur pension au jour monsieur
bonjour vous vous êtes mario simard oui
oui quel est votre profession
représentant représenter ce que vous
dites pro disposal aux lettres ou aux
calculs plutôt beaucoup plus aux calculs
quand même bien évidemment le voir si
vos prédictions se réalisent
je vous précise enfin pour mémoire que
le mot le plus long consiste la façon de
procéder de la façon suivante à dire je
vais tirait cette lettre voyelles et
consonnes que vont l'être revendiquer
les candidats et avec que ces lettres
ils devront fabriquer le mot le plus
long possible mais ici intervient à
notre ami max favalelli qui a le
redoutable honneur de contrôler la
valeur et l'orthographe des mots qui lui
sont proposés il y va d'ailleurs lui
même
quels sont les mots qui sont acceptés ou
le mans qui sont retrouvés à l'heure
voici notre code sont admis à tous les
genres masculin féminin singulier au
pluriel
tous les mots simples composé figurant
dans un dictionnaire scolaire busage
courant dans son édition la plus récente
ainsi que les verbe à l'infinitif et les
partis passer accordé alors que vous
sont refusés les moines une lettre les
interjections les
on ne m'a trotté pur les préfixes des
abréviations les sigles des symboles
chimiques de locutions latines élocution
étrangère même usuelles dans le langage
courant et enfin les noms propres de
lieux ou de personnes
merci maps ovale et nous sommes donc
tout à fait au courant je crois de façon
dont va dérouler le jeu sorte d'accord
monsieur penser aux mêmes courses bien
il ne reste plus qu'à tirer au sort je
pense que je peux me permettre de
demander à même cause de choisir la
première phase et bien c'est pile et
c'est monsieur pension qui va commencer
tout de suite à jouer avec nous au mot
le plus les passions je vous écoute
consonnes
m
bonsoir mesdames bonsoir une demoiselle
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir strasbourg et
bonsoir martin europe stock bon service
et bien ce soir nous allons encore
essayer de faire grossir de petit cochon
rose et pour ce faire nous vous
proposons un petit régime alsacien à
base de choucroute de foie gras et j'en
passe
pour l'année alors lequel des trois de
golf on doit diriger l'eau de jacques
prébois va vous donner la bonne version
2 attention du mot mauviette m à uv aube
du tfc tous bien sûr ce qui est une
mauviette est ce pas jean pierre remy
nous avons appris les candidats dont il
a pas l'air d'avoir comme ça il ya un
imposant s'être senti que monsieur oui
oui les sports pratiqués vous emballe en
bas c'est tout oui un peu de ce qui l
accusait alors du skate qu'ils avaient
également très bien monsieur donc grande
écoute vos trois définitions faudra
choisir la bonne monsieur voilà alors la
première définition de monsieur
l'origine de mauvais goût cette année
par paul préboist alors
le mot mauviette est apparue au 16e
siècle
c'est un diminutif de mots vis movie on
appelait movis les alouettes n'est ce
pas huppé au moyen-âge dans laurier
l'alouette superviser avant la movie ce
joli movie mécanique des pauvres petites
la loi du pays et est jeune donc chétive
malingre un peu soupe aux thèses maladie
movie ce ne soit par l'extension en
diminution en dise et mauviettes été
transporté après quand on a vu quelqu'un
de faible de indiqué mauviette rachète
une mauviette
mais la véritable origine c'est viennent
de ce moment vi qui désignait les
alouettes huppé au moyen-âge et en le
transformer en mauviette pour parler
d'une alouette et qui était plus chère
du bâti de l'air un peu chère suzanne
c'est à vous lasser tout ça mais c'est
par la larme à l'oeil non en réalité
c'est un mot d'origine latine
ça vient du mot mysa c'est un nom de
plantes c'est une plante qui était
mauvais qu'avait la propriété de soigner
à peu près toutes les maladies les
maladies de tous les malades qui étaient
des gens totalement chétif fatalement
souffreteux est le nom de cette plante
est devenu d'abord move est parce que
les thèmes moraux et jolie et puis après
ça s'est transformé en mauviettes
avec sa s'approchait des à la fois des
malades et de la plante donc c'est une
plante d'origine latine ça n'a rien à
voir avec les alouettes
du fait de très beau aboyer voilà donc
maintenant la troisième origine celle de
jacques blanc viennent c'est pas du tout
du latin c'est un mot du vieil anglais
mauvais et qui veut dire maigre et qui
signifiait et qui fut repris par les
français qui ajoutaient le diminutif est
synonyme de petit et qui donnera par la
suite personnes maigres chétive
mauviettes
voilà je récapitule pour vous si vous
voulez bien monsieur alors pour paul
préboist vient du diminutif movie ce qui
était le nom de l'alouette huppé au
moyen-âge et les petites salles ouais tu
paies et on les a appelés ensuite des
mauviettes c était tout petit
susan gabrielle au vient du latin malva
qui voulait dire mauvais puis ensuite
mauvais tu es puis montviette c'était
une plante qui servait à soigner les
personnes malades et pour jacques
prébois n'est pas d'accord du tout avec
ses deux partenaires vient du vieil
anglais mao qui signifie [ __ ] alors qui
a la bonne origine des trois heures la 2
ou hazard l'a26 taire susan gabrielle
open cabrio non messieurs c'est pas ça
du tout c'était pour passer vraiment
logique bien en réalité
en réalité c'est paul prévoit j'avais la
bonne voiture n ya ni de végétal j'étais
du règne animal
ma vie c'était vraiment tu vas pas tout
recommencer et c'est effectivement la
loi est super mec une mauviette
pas seulement pour finir jean pierre le
bailleur alors